okay guys so welcome to another edition
of my greatest losses the past couple of
weeks I've been showing you games that I
lose obviously if it with a silver
lining so at the end I'll show you a
game where I learned a lesson from my
losses and then I applied it to a game
and I won and everything was nice since
this is going to be my last greatest
losses during this stint that I'm doing
as your GM in residence I am pulling the
brakes there was gonna be no silver
linings today we're not gonna waste any
time with these fluffy emotions and
we're just gonna go straight to the meat
and potatoes and I'm going to show you
devastating losses that I suffered
recently and some of them maybe not so
recent but I wanted to start with this
game with a game which I remember when I
was playing it I was feeling very
nervous because I felt am I playing the
greatest game of my life
this is quite possible and it would have
been but it wasn't so let's get started
I was playing with white against a
grandmaster from Argentina
named Reuben Phil Geyer
he's currently semi-retired but in his
peak he was number one in Argentina and
his rating was something like twenty six
thirty and he was doing really well in
Europe winning open tournaments really
well in the feed a World Cup making it
to the second or third round so I was
playing in one of the top boards I don't
know if it was like board two or three
in the continental championship which is
basically the event that spans all the
way from Canada in the north to
Argentina in the South and if you want
to qualify for the World Cup that's a
great chance to do it so this was round
one I was playing with white
my opponent went d6 and after a d4
Knight f6 Knight c3 c6 and now I played
f4 so does anybody know this opening has
anybody ever seen it it's a very odd
system for black yes this is the
Austrian attack but the Austrian attack
proper is against the perc defense which
is when black plays g6 and then we see
the move F for Bishop g7 Knight f3 and
Castle kingside
if you like crazy games this is the
opening for you this line became very
very famous as a powerful tool for the
white side when he Karim Nakamura won a
brilliant game against Ilyas Mirren
Grandmaster from Israel with the move e5
and after 97 h4 just going for an
all-out King side attack so that's
definitely a game worth looking up if
you want to understand the system a
little bit better but the difference
when black plays c6 is that he still
have it hasn't really told me what he's
gonna do with this Bishop so if he goes
g6 I can play for a similar idea but
this added flexibility that the c6 move
gives him can take the sting out of
whites attack so after f4 Queen a5 so
creating the first threat of the game
Knight takes pawn
so I defend against that with Bishop d3
and now after E 5 Knight f3
he takes d4 Knight takes d4 so we see
that black is still keeping this Bishop
on f8 flexible and waiting for me to
sort of show him my hand right am I
gonna play in the center am I going to
play on the King side and according to
that that's where the black bishop will
get developed so now he finally plays g6
because it
quite obvious that I'm not going to be
able to go for anything like h4 h5 I'm
also going to have a very hard time
playing a5 so blacks King side is going
to be safe
by the way instead of g6 there was a
very famous opening trap I hope I can
remember it that goes something like
this and after night b3 a5 and white
would really like to Castle here so how
would you guys try to carry out this
maneuver right how would you go about
castling as white what do you need to
Castle what do you need to do right we
have to do something about this Queen
that's making it illegal for us to
Castle so you would ideally want to get
a Bishop to e3 then the Queen will have
to move and then you can Castle but of
course we can't put our Bishop on e3
right away because the Queen takes the
bishop so how can we prepare this move
Queen e2 excellent very logical right
now let's say that black continues with
the idea Knight d2 but now mmm right so
white reasoned oh I'll just throw in the
move Bishop e3 first that way when the
Queen moves I can play Knight d2 and I
won't block my own Bishop on c1 but
black plays the move Queen to b4 and now
after a3 very unpleasant surprise here
is this how it went
he takes I believe so
is 8 takes b3 and after eight takes
before rook takes a1 and you say oh no
problem I'll just go 91 but what can
black play here yeah so Bishop g4 and
White has to resign because you're going
to lose your queen right if if you go
Queen d2 well black is just going to
take on d1 and after all these trades
black is simply up a piece right we have
three pieces only has two and if you say
well I don't have to give back my queen
I can just go here well then you get
checkmated so very nice opening trap I
always like to show it when I show this
game because these are the kind of
opening traps that are really useful why
is this trap useful because white made
all of the logical moves right white
said oh I want a castle so I need to put
my Bishop on e3 in order to put my
bishop on e3 I can put my queen on e2
and that fails spectacularly to this
very nice opening trick fortunately my
opponent didn't go for this opening trap
I don't know if I would have been able
to to solve it in case you guys are
wondering the best move against Queen b6
is not to decentralize your knight but
rather just to drop back with your
Bishop to e2 so this protects your
knight and most importantly allows you
to castle on the next move
instead black played the move g6
and after Castle kingside Bishop g7 King
h1 just getting out of any potential
pins along this diagonal Castle King
side and now Bishop e3 another useful
thing about King H 1 is if black ever
goes Knight g4 I can tuck my bishop away
on g1 this was not true of Bishop e3
right away cuz in 94 is a huge huge
problem so Bishop b3 rook to e8 and now
Queen d2 and 97 at this point I would
say the opening is over and how do you
know when the opening is over yeah
yeah I think that usually there's
there's three parameters that you can
look at number one is your King's safety
so have you put your King in a safe
place it doesn't necessarily have to be
castling sometimes your King is safer in
the center but I would say like ninety
percent of the times it means castling
number two your piece placement have you
really put your pieces on decent squares
I mean they don't have to be the best
wears ever but I think if we look at
White's position we can say that okay
this looks pretty reasonable for white
all the pieces are in the center later
if one of them can be improved we can
spend some time to do that but overall I
was satisfied with my development and
then your pawn structure that would be
the third key feature of a position to
look at so in terms of the pawn
structure are we controlling the center
do we have any pawn weaknesses that we
can try to fix those kinds of things and
here also White's pawn structure it
looks pretty good I would say white is
slightly better because if we take the
same approach from blacks side we see
that black really hasn't completely
finished development right we see this
Bishop on c8 that hasn't come out yet
and it's gonna need at least a couple
more moves to come out a potential
weakness on d6 right this a backward
pawn there could be a problem and the
King's safety what do you think about
blacks King does it look safe
no I not okay so this is actually one of
the most common misconceptions about the
fianchetto
is that it's a particularly safe house
for the King and I think this isn't
really true I think what the fianchetto
does is it gives your bishop have really
nice diagonal but it makes your King
particularly vulnerable to attacks
because you have what in chess we call a
hook on g6 has anybody heard this term
hook
have you heard it because I've said it
okay good
so what do you understand by hook so a
hook is basically a anytime you've made
a pawn move in the position surrounding
your king usually your castle allows a
contact point for whites pieces
specifically pawns to open up files on
your king
I mean sometimes it doesn't have to be a
pawn for example if you had played let's
say your pawn to h6 you would also have
a hook here on h6 that would allow me a
way to make contact with your Kings
position but here we have a clear hook
on g6 and like you said at some point
white can play f5 and start opening up
the position so Janka Dov's aren't
necessarily the safest arrangement for
your King I mean think of the dragon
variation of the Sicilian one of the
most dangerous Sicilians to be playing
as black when white plays for an attack
with the Yugoslav for example so I
played the move a three and after Queen
to c7 Knight to f3 no what do you think
of this move it looks a little bit
strange
what could the idea be okay so at some
point I'll play Knight to g5 maybe not
right away because black will go
something like h6 but in general the
Knights feel very happy when they're
sitting behind their pawns so it's
useful to compare the situation of the
knight on c3 with the situation of the
knight on f3 this is a universal
principle so it doesn't just have to do
with this position you can apply it to
any kind of position for example the
Sicilian would be a great example so if
the black pawn were on e7 instead of c6
we would have a dragon Sicilian
basically and the knight on c3 would
still be misplaced I would say even
worse than it is now because black would
have the C file to put pressure on it oh
that's cool I didn't know just not
getting highlighted if I do this stuff
nevermind Knights love to sit behind
their pawns and they don't like to sit
in front of them so a perfect
illustration of this concept that I'm
talking about can be seen right here so
it's true I'm taking my knight away from
the center with Knight f3 but at the
same time it's not going to be as
exposed on d4 and like you said
eventually if a King side attack
develops like this I can try to bring my
Knight to g5 another idea as we'll see
after the move b5 is that I can play
Bishop to d4 which improves the
situation of my bishop notice that this
bishop on e3 isn't too happy because
it's let's do that and no let's do that
in red
because bishops have a big problem when
they're being restricted by their own
pawns one of the most important things
that you can do in the opening is avoid
putting a pawn on f4 when you have a
bishop on c1 because that's going to
make your Bishop severely restricted so
one way you can solve this is by trying
to maneuver your Bishop out of the pawn
chain like this or or in this case by
putting the bishop on d4 because now the
bishop enjoys an open diagonal and I
would love to trade dark square bishop
because that's just gonna highlight the
weaknesses alone two dark squares of
blacks can keto so my opponent plays
this move Bishop h6 which by the way is
a fairly deep move and when I say fairly
deep move it just means deep but not
deep enough because I mean it's such an
odd move what could be the idea what do
you think that black is trying to do or
accomplish with Bishop h6
is that a hand yeah right so first of
all I can't push f5 second lead maybe
black can play Knight h5 on the next
move and not have to trade dark square
bishop s' also increasing the pressure
on f4 but I think most importantly my
opponent realized that my idea was to
play queen f2 and Queen h4 and swing my
queen over to the king site for example
if black played something like a5 I was
probably going to start with Queen f2
and after rook b8 I would do something
like Queen h4 and we start seeing how
White's pieces are creeping closer and
closer to the black King so now I would
definitely consider playing moves like
f5 and Knight g5 because my queen is
gonna help in the attack so Bishop h6
seems like a very deep move because when
we go at h5 we won't trade the bishops
but also if we go Queen f2 we're gonna
drop the pawn on f4 right does everybody
understand the logic behind Bishop h6
okay now what would you play is white
yeah
95 okay very interesting and can we do
something g5 looks very very reasonable
and what's your idea if we do something
like this
what's that g3 okay and maybe here
well I was hoping you wouldn't do g4 but
I think you put if you're gonna go g4
you might as well do it right away yeah
so I really can't get away with this
because you're just gonna go Queen takes
so maybe 9 h5 is just too soon what if I
start with a 6
okay very interesting because taking on
g5 looks way too dangerous right like if
I do it here giving up that dark square
bishop is not gonna be a good idea
although I mean how would the game
continue here maybe this isn't so bad it
looks very bad
okay but what I was hoping to do was use
this key five outpost right so after
here maybe I can go Bishop e6
and this is a very nice night and it
doesn't seem like we can really take
advantage of the dark squares right away
so maybe black can hold this but it does
look very suspicious so 95 is definitely
an interesting move has anybody ever
heard of Sam Shanklin Yeah right do you
know that aside from being a good chess
player a very good chess player he also
writes very interesting books and makes
very interesting videos did you know
that well he does and I was actually
watching one of his videos where it's
called the Sam Shanklin method and he
actually does have a method it's not
just a gimmick it's a very interesting
method that he uses and it's a tool that
he uses for calculation and he says that
whenever you're trying to make an idea
work what you should do is ask yourself
okay what is the idea that I'm trying to
play how is my opponent preventing me
from carrying out that idea and what
happens if I play it anyway so what is
the point of this way of thinking well a
lot of the times we get spooked by our
opponents move like Bishop h6 and we
think Oh Bishop h6 has prevented me from
playing Queen f2 but what Shankman would
tell you to do here would be go a step
farther or further worse Denis LaRue
he's good at grammar stuff okay what is
it further go a step further and see
what happens if black really is
preventing you from carrying out your
idea don't just take his word for it so
I played the move Queen f2
and what's gonna be the follow-up if
Bishop takes f4 g3 I don't think it's
gonna be g3 because then I think the
bishop can just go back with a belly
full of pawns right Queen h4 which was
the original idea of queen f2 and sure I
lost the pawn but at the same time I
have opened up the F file right so this
is gonna help me carry out my attack
even better so it's important not to get
boxed in taking our opponents word for
it when he appears to be preventing our
idea it might not be and also it's
important not to get too attached to
material when you're thinking about
attacking what was the book called
well has anybody heard of Joseph Dorfman
French Grandmaster very famous coach he
came up with a series of books I think
they're also called like my method so
everybody has a method but a couple of
people actually have good methods so
Shanklin would be one and Dorfman would
be another and he came up with this I
would call it like different levels of
different priority levels where he would
place King safety at the very top of the
totem pole then you would have material
then you would have I don't know like
pawn structure and number or I forget
what it was but it wasn't very important
so in this case we have two of these
variables at play we have material so
the pawn on f4 and we have king safety
the King on g8 so which one's going to
be more important according to Dorfman
he would say this is a classic case
where that pawn is easily compensated
because King safety Trump's material
and besides a pawn isn't a lot of
material anyway so my opponent goes
Bishop to e5 and how do we follow up
with the attack
brilliant so there might not be an
immediate threat although there is but
trading the dark square bishop Sui
already-established is a major
achievement for white because now look
at all these dark squares that have been
left unprotected
on the Kings side so at least 95 clears
the F file so that we can maybe play
something like rook f3 followed by rook
a to f1 maybe or a rook lifts to h3
right something like this but also black
needs to be very very careful here
because I might be threatening to take
on f7 and after King takes Queen takes
h7 does everybody see that because the
knight on f6 is gonna be pinned so my
opponent played King g7 and he's arguing
that okay maybe I can snack on f7 which
is what I did and then he can go Knight
g8 so he gives back the pawn but he
starts taking control over some dark
squares and I don't have a clear way of
breaking through here so how do we
continue the attack
okay so 95 and what happens if we bring
this other knight to f6 for example
all right so where would you put your
rook well there's a difference if you go
here first I'm going to start chasing
some of your pieces away because I don't
like them so close to my king so it
looks like you have to move your knight
and now I could take on h3 but I could
also start annoying you with moves like
Bishop to g4 as well breaking up your
coordination I think that White's attack
seems to be losing steam here so instead
I played Bishop takes b5 again King
safety turns out to be more important
than material and the idea is that after
C takes b5 this Bishop that really well
isn't doing anything on d3 all it was
doing was crashing into my own pawns now
provides a very useful square on d5 for
my knight so my knight on c3
which wasn't happy sitting in front of
its own pawn
finds this beautiful outpost on d5 and
when the Queen moves all of a sudden now
your idea 95 is a lot stronger because
with a knight on d5 we've taken control
over the f6 square so black played the
move Knight d f6 anyway and how do we
play here well you're gonna have to be
more specific
okay
mm-hmm okay and after Queen takes after
King here
and we're down a rook you're on to the
right idea though but it just doesn't
work so straightforward
now if we follow Yosef Dorfman's
principle which states that King safety
is more important than material hold on
what you say anyway and after Knight
takes King h6 it's not that easy if we
value King's safety over material we
would gladly give up one of our pieces
that's doing nothing in order to advance
our attempt so remember when we had this
Bishop on b3 doing nothing we sacrificed
it in order to activate the knight
so we traded a piece that was doing
nothing in order to get a piece to a
better square now which one of whites
pieces is doing nothing the rook on a1
it's the only piece that's not
participating in the attack so how can
we try to get it involved
very nice
so now rook f1 so it's much better to
give up the rook on a1 than it is to
give up the knight on d5 even though
Knights are worth less than roots in
this case that's not true because
material doesn't matter as much as King
safety so now we're threatening to take
the knight and obviously Knight d5 fails
because of Queen takes 8 7 mate so black
played h6 and what do we do now
any ideas
right this looks devastating right we're
gonna have a double check mate right so
also hmm maybe after Knight takes f6 is
is this move possible probably not
but you're saying you're saying this
move and now after here King takes yeah
and I guess I'm threatening the night
and you don't have any good discoveries
so you would probably have to take on h6
which looks kind of interesting but
probably not a big deal although this is
not a bad position in the game I played
rook takes f6 with a very similar idea
and that is if you go H takes g5 well
here I can just go Queen takes and my
next move is going to be to take on g6
with mate to follow shortly so here
black played Bishop e6 I think that if
you go Queen takes f6 will get the same
position that you were mentioning right
takes takes and now Queen takes this
should be better for white maybe against
Knight takes f6 though do I have any
choice here I mean it does this even
work
if you go something like here
threatening the rook I don't think I
mean can I go g5 because if Knight takes
d5 then I can take this knight on f6
well I'm threatening your queen and I'm
also threatening nothing else we're here
here Queen f2
the problem is that I'm you know kind of
down in exchange well you're gonna take
this so you're going at age five as well
yeah this actually looks very
interesting for white because if I go
here at night H five is devastating and
if I go I don't know
Bishop somewhere you can just take the
rook and after it takes then you have
Knight h5 anyway actually a very
interesting idea a knight takes f6 I
played rook takes and now black played
Bishop e6 we can't stop now
so how do we keep the attack rolling
the funny thing is black is actually
threatening to play rook to f8 believe
it or not because let's say insert null
move after rogue f8 we can't really play
Knight takes c6 because of Queen takes
and we're gonna have some back rank
problems and if Rick takes g6 after King
takes what are you gonna do
all right it's gonna be a total order
because you're running out of pieces
what check here and you don't really
have any more checks so we have to
create one more threat I mean so far it
seems like black is barely holding by
the skin of his teeth but he is holding
so the pressure on e6 is just not enough
to crack blacks position so they move
Knight f7 and this creates the threat of
Queen takes h6 so black has to give up
the Queen I mean there's just no way of
protecting h6 and right because if work
to h8 I think now we can definitely do
this yeah if King takes then we have
check and checkmate and if King takes g6
I think we have Knight takes e5 at the
very least does anybody see checkmate
here green f6 King h7 Queen h6 King g8
oh there it is
that's even better oops
right oh here here and here
and if King eh Queenie seven and if King
g8 well it's not checkmate
maybe oh it is check me actually is it I
saw all of that I'm just pretending like
I didn't so we're actually threatening
rook takes g6 as well as Queen it takes
h6 so Blanc just has to give in and
trade the Queen for some of my pieces
and the hopes that it won't be checkmate
and Micah actually succeeds because now
after rook takes c6 Bishop takes c6
Knight takes h6 it's only two rooks
right and here black plays rook f8 what
do you guys think of this position this
is white better black better what's
going on
yes
yes I wish someone had told me that
during the game and what would you do in
order to solve that problem
yeah and actually h3 would have been the
correct move and white is close to
winning here because even though black
seems to have material balance or
equality even this King is still in
trouble and if black tries to win my
night I'm going to be able to let's say
sacrifice the night and then get this
bishop back and in this open position
that Queen is going to be much stronger
than the two rooks so for example if
King g8 Queen e6 can you do 7 I can even
take this pawn first and again when the
King moves check King here I can take I
have a queen and three pawns against two
rooks this is a hopeless endgame way
yeah where
here king h7 well I can go here right I
don't think you have any squares where
you can escape the the fork so h3 yes
very good move what would be another way
of dealing with basically the only
threat yeah okay so the reason I don't
like Queenie wants so much is because
now we do lose a very important piece
right our night on h6 does need the
Queen to defend it for now
g3 does solve the problem but I am a
little bit worried about opening up this
diagonal on my king that could lead to
trouble eventually so the other move
that I like for white is king g1 which
basically takes away that checkmating
square but h3 is by far the best move
because the king can escape here we
don't weaken our light squares either
and I think white just has a really big
advantage because if black doesn't play
rook h8 we're just gonna go either
Knight g4 or Queen g5 and this King on
g7 is having an awful time it's after
rook f8 I was very low on time and
entered into a panic I was already a
little bit surprised that I hadn't
checkmated my opponent I thought my
attack was super brilliant and that my
opponent would just collapse emotionally
and he did not I mean
26:40 player will not collapse so easily
so I played the move Knight f5 which is
a horrendous blunder because I thought
oh this is the same as rook h8 I'll just
give some checks and pick up the bishop
on c6 and I'll have a winning position
and after G takes f 5 I don't really
need to worry about the checkmate on f1
this is this was very superficial
calculation because after I
well I played queen g5 the only move
really was Queen d7 and after check
Queen g5 and I think I have a perpetual
check because if this King ever goes to
f8 I can just go Queen h6 and pick up
the Bishop leading to a very similar
endgame to the one we just talked about
so black would have to go for this
perpetual but already I mean having to
draw as white in a completely from a
completely winning position is not
something desirable that Queen g5
doesn't even draw because now the King
can just march over to the Queen side
and defend the bishop
so after takes King g7 takes King d7
sure right took a bunch of pawns but
this Bishop on c6 is not just going to
give black a lot of pressure but it's
also going to give black perfect king
safety once this King reaches the b7
square because I won't be able to attack
along life swears so the game quickly
ended here after h3 rook e8 Jack here
queen c3 and king b7 I played a couple
more moves but now it's just over Black
has a big material lead and my king now
it ironically it's my king that is
unsafe and it's black King that's
perfectly safe yeah well in the u.s.
using delay is very common but
everywhere else in the world they've
never even heard of time delay they use
increment so in this tournament
I forget the time control I think maybe
it was game 90 but was this thirty
second increment for move one so you
never have less than 30 seconds to make
a move and if you make a lot of moves
very quickly your time actually adds up
as opposed to delay you never have more
time than what you already have that
your clock simply won't start ticking
down so here I could have had 30 seconds
I could have made a couple of moves
quickly and I would have had two minutes
so it's hard to tell
that's why normally I like to write down
the times next to each or one of my
moves so I can see how low on time it
really was to see if my bad move was a
product of time trouble or simply
miscalculation also so I can see how I'm
managing or miss managing my time where
I took the most time thinking about a
move so what moments do I feel are
critical in a game that I need to spend
a lot of time on I remember David
Bronstein former contender for the World
Championship title was a big advocate of
this idea he's probably one of the first
players to do this methodically taking
down the times on every move so I've
been doing it for years I mean maybe it
consumes a little bit of extra time but
it's probably worth it even if you get a
little bit of insight every now and then
it should help you it won't hurt I don't
think so
mmm in the next couple of moves I went
green b5 and after a rook f8 I was just
like okay this is enough and I just
resigned I can't stop him from playing
rook G 2 followed by well not
necessarily rook F 1
but after rook G 2 my king is gonna have
to go to h1 and then there's gonna be
some massive discoveries there nothing
good can happen so yeah this one was
pretty painful the silver lining though
I promised I wouldn't do this but hey I
can't help myself was that this was for
the first round and then in the second
round I felt oh well I lost but that was
a really interesting game so I'm playing
well so I should do really well in this
tournament so I lost my second round too
and I got completely crushed against a
much lower rated player like a 2000
player so I thought if I almost beat at
26:30 this 2,000 player I'm just gonna
crush him and I exhaustion like 20 moves
after that after that humbling
experience I managed to win five games
in a row against some really good
players - I think that was the first
time I beat a grandmaster
in a tournament and they actually beat
three of them like in a row so I was
like whoa yeah finally so then when I
felt oh now I'm invincible I lost my
last three rounds in a row
- so hurry emotional player I had one
draw actually yeah but it was it was a
crazy game - so it was just kind of a by
accident that I managed to draw a game
actually I uh I won six games in a row
not five then I drew the seventh and I
lost like the last three it was
something ridiculous
it's a good question they really if
they're really adding up it was eleven
rounds so wait I lost the first two I
won five so that's seven and they lost
no so I won six and then I lost the last
three yeah no I won five and drew one
and then I lost the last three so I
scored five and a half out of eleven but
I got my first international master norm
anyway
game what would it be nine and round
nine if I had won my game I would
actually scored a GM norm which back
then was worth double because it was a
feat a World Championship qualifier so
if you score a norm in those tournaments
it actually it's worth - I don't know
why but it was nice now it's not like
that anymore so don't get excited but
yeah so that was a that was a tough one
but it was a good learning experience
let's see this is live right so we can't
like head it's tough out if I'm like
loading up another game
I don't can't it's no problem nevermind
just don't worry about it
like if chess bass crashes alright so
this one I don't think was nearly as
crazy as the one I just showed you but
it did have one interesting moment in
the game and I would say that this game
was even more painful than the one I
just showed you because this was a last
round whereas the one we just saw was a
first round so when you have the first
round you have the whole tournament
ahead of you so no matter how bad things
get you say well it's not doesn't matter
how you start but how you finish but
when you lose the last round you're like
oh okay so now it's finished the end it
was terrible and that was the case with
a would you say like Pepe is a chess
celebrity I would say so I mean he's
known in every corner of the world
because of the broadcasts he does for
chess 24 pepe cuenca yeah this guy is a
grandmaster from Spain
he's a very lively commentator even if
you don't understand Spanish you should
check out some of his chest 24 videos
he's like screaming all the time it's
pretty interesting and he was actually
here at the club not too long ago yeah
and he did a broadcast from the club
anyway I felt like I had prepared for
this game fairly well because I owe
Jesus what happened what'd I do tracee
start from the beginning yeah okay so in
this game I don't know if you all are
familiar with the term preparing for a
game yeah well in case you're not I mean
preparing for a game isn't just like you
know brushing your teeth and tying your
shoelaces getting you're getting your
chess set and your pen and I'm prepared
now now preparing for a game actually
means looking up your opponent in a
database seeing if they have any games
and if they do have games you study them
and you try to pinpoint some of their
strengths and weaknesses and you choose
an opening based on that so when I
prepared for this game I realized my
opponent was a very solid positional
player so if I could find an opening
variation where for example I could grab
a pawn this is something I never do but
if I could grab a pawn and he had to
compensate it by getting some crazy
attacker initiative I knew he would have
to be outside of his comfort zone and
that's really what I wanted so I wanted
not necessarily a position that was
better for me but one that would be
difficult for him to play according to
his style so in that regard I think the
opening went beautifully I'll just go
through the first few moves quickly
because I played this theoretical
variation which forces white to
sacrifice a pawn this pawn on c4 so he
went Bishop to g2 by the way it doesn't
really force him to sacrifice the pawn
you can also go a four but things get
pretty messy here this is an English
opening so he decided to go Bishop g2
and I was like okay I'm not entirely
sure this is a fantastic line for black
but I do feel like he's not going to
feel at ease playing this kind of
position so he went before and after
Bishop to b4 Queen c2
I played nine a five just getting my
night out of trouble and after castles
d6 so this is exactly what I'm referring
to here you can't just improve your
position as white you can't play like h3
rook e1 and hope for the best because
black is just gonna Castle and go Bishop
d7 finish developing and we're just
gonna be up a pond so my opponent played
Bishop e3 which is a useful move
develops and attacks my queen and after
Queen c7 he's almost running out of easy
moves to make and if he's not careful
like I said I'm just gonna Castle and be
up at pawn so he played rook F c1 and
now I played Bishop takes c3 and if I
can trade Queens and that's a that's a
home run for me so he goes Queen d3 if
Queen takes c3 I can probably just trade
and after rook takes during the game I I
think I was just gonna trade these
Knights and I know after something like
this maybe go a6 and I felt like this
position was probably okay for me is it
because I can also try something like
knight c6 and I think this doesn't
really lead to a great game for white so
he went Queen d3 trying to keep the
Queen's on the board and capture with
the rook on c3 and then double up along
the C file so after knight c6 rook takes
now I played Knight g4 and so far I was
pretty happy with how I was playing
because the point of 94 is that white
isn't just trying to go rook c1 actually
if I'm not careful white really wants to
go rook d1 and get his pawn back on d6
after which is going to have the bishop
pair and I'm going to be behind in
development
it well if I go rook d8 here I think I
have some problems along the C file as
well let's see was this rook the eight I
don't know if he can go Knight d4 what
was bothering me here I think it was 94
and now I'm threatening Knight b5 well
you can't take the knight you could try
to go a six but now things start getting
a little bit dangerous right maybe
Bishop f4 well e five runs into Bishop
takes e5 so it felt like Y it was
getting quite a bit of pressure so I was
happy with this move Knight g4 I'm not
really forced to Castle yet and you
don't really have a good square for this
Bishop because if you go back to c1 you
block your rook and if you go back to d2
you block the D file so when the work
comes to d1 you don't really have
pressure against d6 and if you go to f4
well this is just going to help me
because I want to play e5 and Bishop e6
and I also want to take away the d4
square for the knight so he played
Bishop d2 anyway and now I went a five
because White's main idea is to go
ninety four ninety five and now this
night on b3 is misplaced
so after h3 my knight can come back it's
done its job and now he plays Knight a5
very tricky move so the point is that if
I take here he's just going to go rook
takes c6 and then row takes d6 on the
next move getting the pawn back with a
big advantage so simply castles and now
after b4 Knight takes b4 things start to
get pretty complicated
if rook takes c7 just take the Queen and
after takes we trade everything in black
is just up upon with a beautiful night
on cc5 so again white wants to keep the
Queen's on the board he goes Queen b5 so
I go Queen b6 again looking for the
Queen trade and now after Queen a4 I
think we arrived at the critical moment
of the game Black has a much better
position I mean Black is up to pawns the
bishop on g2 really isn't contributing
too much how do we consolidate the
position is black
what looks well it looks concerning
about blacks position that you would
really want to address and fix yeah okay
so Bishop d7 is a very tempting move and
it's actually what I played and it turns
out to be a slight mistake well yes and
no this looks like a weakness
but it's actually not so bad it's one of
those backwards pawns that you encounter
a lot in the Sicilian that looks weak
but white can never really take
advantage of it and it's not easy for
white to attack this pawn so it's not a
concern at least not at the moment what
else looks bad about blacks position
there's something that's just like
staring at you from the board that looks
like about to lose something yeah this
Knight on before whenever you see a
knight floating around the board this
should be a major source of of tactics
and threats Knights like to be on
outposts they like to be protected by
pawns where they can't be attacked by
opponents pawns so this is really the
problem to fix this is what's going to
define whether black can consolidate the
advantage and get a winning position or
not so how can we do that how can we get
the knight to a safe square ideally an
outpost yeah
okay the problem with ninety-six though
is that y can just take this
then after tapes rook takes and now this
d6 pawn can definitely become a problem
right Wow
yes so Knight a six a very
counterintuitive move because it takes
the knight away from the center but
prepares to relocate it on c5 now this
is going to be a beautiful square for
the knight first of all because it's an
outpost but secondly because it's going
to shut down the C file so White's not
going to get any counterplay along the C
file and I think White's just busted
here white could try something like
ninety four but the Queen will just
retreat and now I'll develop the bishop
and will constantly be able to create
threats on the knight on c4 and then
play ninety five so just something like
this for example I can even give back a
pawn although here you can't really take
the pawn I don't think because I'm gonna
for Q at the end so I'm not saying that
the game is over after Knight f6 but I
do have two extra pawns and a pretty
good position overall but instead I
played Bishop d7 and here the game
starts to spiral out of control after
Queen a3 I went for the knight c6 idea
because I figured okay now c6 is safe
after rook b3 queen c5 Knight b7 takes
takes Knight d4 rook t1 white doesn't
have enough time to take on d6 because
of 92 so I still felt pretty decent like
I was in an endgame where I was up upon
but now d6 is weak so this should give
white enough counter play to more or
less keep the balance after Bishop c6
Knight d6 wrote the 894 Bishop takes e4
I'm still up upon
and you can't take on e5 here because
after 96 you are stuck on the D file for
a very long time so rookie three takes
takes e4 Bishop a5 and again time
trouble is your greatest enemy in chess
if you're a time trouble addict you've
probably lost a lot of games that you
shouldn't have and in this game I am yet
again in time trouble and even though
it's an end game I'm and I am up a pawn
it's basically a roll of the die and I
got Snake Eyes again so Rick d5 rook a
396 rook c1 and rook e8 and very soon I
started to run into some tactics that I
had not anticipated so now after Knight
d6 this game starts to go in White's
direction and after rook c4 93 Knight
takes rook takes rook takes e4 what is a
problem in blacks position to you well
it looks like something that we should
probably take care of now before it's
too late and I think you have a good eye
at spotting these things because you
picked up on it in the previous game
any ideas
there you go so the back rank is a huge
problem because there's only one rook
guarding it the other rook is doing I
don't know what on d5 and we don't have
any squares yeah for our King so what
would you play here
yeah h6 great move this is what I should
have played kind of like h3 in the
previous game I'm actually sensing a
pattern so instead I said well I'll just
throw in rook d7
I'll get this annoying Bishop out of c7
I'll overprotect
a 7a prevent white from playing rookie 7
I mean look at all the advantages of
rook d7 what a brilliant move and this
is where it's just over now because I
went from being up at pawn to being down
upon in like two moves and not only that
White has this tremendous outside passer
on a 2 which is gonna start flying down
the a file very soon so I have to move
after Bishop d6 takes takes I want f6
but after a 4 this is just over so the
game went on a few more moves that white
basically Queen D a pawn fairly easily
so that's it so thanks to everybody for
sticking around and in attending the
lecture is not just this one but the
ones over the past couple of weeks I
enjoyed having you and I hope to see you
guys in my next trip out here to st.
Louis
you
[Music]
you